>> So how do scientists know which genetic factors to look at?
Couldn't there be thousands or even
millions of possible variations and mutations?
>> This is true. And, sometimes scientists, even have the
hard time determining what the genetic factors are for a given
complex trait. Especially if it has a moderate to low heritability.
And this is a genome-wide association studies and SNVs come in.
>> Genome-wide association
studies look at SNVs and other genetic factors
across the whole genome to find correlation between
specific alleles and the trait or disorder being
studied. The method is almost exactly the same as
the skin-rash association study we just looked at
in the last exercise. Except instead of just
one genetic factor, GWAS or Genome Wide Association
Studies look at hundreds or thousands or even millions
of factors at once. They're looking at
the whole genome. This method takes full advantage
of all of our SNVs, all of our single nucleotide variations and uses them as
sign posts for different phenotypes or traits.
And although this can be a really powerful
tool, it doesn't always yield clear results as
we'll see with an example of bipolar disorder.